all right so let's want to say a few
things about this Colin Kapernick
situation as as you as you know I'm sure
Colin Kaepernick is the new face of Nike
and they're believed in something even
if it means sacrificing everything
campaigned very inspiring very inspiring
stuff way that is the tagline right yeah
believe in something yeah that's the
tagline the the new commercial wasn't
veiled I believe it officially debuts
today as a matter of fact but there was
a sneak peek a sneak peek of the
commercial came out yesterday and it's
so the commercial is is Kaepernick
narrating over images of various
athletes doing doing legitimately
courageous things like there's one
there's an athlete who's overcame a
brain tumor another who became a
wrestler even though he doesn't have
legs and then the camera cuts back to
Colin Kaepernick and Kaepernick is
actually smothering a bald eagle with a
burning American flag and so I was that
was a little bit provocative but not
surprised no actually
Kaepernick he just says a bunch of
generically inspiring cliches about
following your dreams and so forth and
then the LAT the last line of the
commercial it was the last line of the
commercial is so don't ask if your
dreams are crazy
ask if they're crazy enough which is one
of those lines that a mean I guess it
sounds inspiring it doesn't mean
anything ask if your dreams are crazy
enough like that's that's supposed to be
your driving the the philosophy that
drives your life so I know that dreams
not crazy enough no I need crazier
dreams yeah is that what you would tell
your kids yeah your kid says to you you
know I want to be a doctor no it's not
crazy enough you need to come back here
with crazier dreams okay I want really
crazy dude okay I want to fly to Mars
there you go that should be your goal
flying tomorrow now that's a crazy dream
go chase it um anyway it's all pretty
pretty innocuous the commercial is
innocuous and in fact I find Kaepernick
himself to be in general a pretty
innocuous character I'm just not I am
not naturally filled with the kind of
blind rage about Colin Kaepernick that a
lot of other conservatives seem to be
filling I never have been I I haven't
been able to generate the anger
especially the sustained anger that so
many conservatives have about Colin
Kaepernick three years later they're so
still so angry at this guy i I couldn't
I I mean listen and that tells you
something because if I'm not able to
stay angry at about Colin Kaepernick I
don't know how anyone else can
because usually staying angry it's one
of the skills that I have I do think
it's it's kind of amazing that we're
still talking about this three years
later and it seems to be it's part of
this trend that I've pointed out before
where both sides of the political divide
they seem to kind of pick out stars the
Stars and the spokesman for the other
side so the right made stars out of
David hog Alexandra okayso Cortes Colin
Kaepernick and then the left made a
president out of Donald Trump
they both accomplished that for the
other side by being utterly completely
obsessed with these people like
conservatives are obsessed with
Alexandria okayso courses I mean easily
90% of the coverage that I see and read
about this woman comes from
conservatives the same thing with David
Hogg and it's definitely the same thing
with Colin Kaepernick if the
Conservatives are obsessed with these
people that kid they just can't give him
that get him out of their head and the
same thing on the other end happen and
it's happened with other things with
leftist but obviously the biggest
example is Donald Trump Donald Trump
came on the scene and liberals just
obsessed with the guy liberal media
obsessed with him and he became
president which I think it's an
interesting phenomenon and maybe not a
good strategy maybe a better strategy
like if you're on the right and there's
somebody on the left that you think is
really stupid ridiculous shallow
inconsequential irrelevant all of these
things maybe the best thing is to treat
them that way and to ignore them
and then you'll root you'll stop hearing
about them
maybe that but maybe that would be the
best strategy
certainly with colin kaepernick if
conservatives had just ignored for the
most part this you know his uh his
protest of the national anthem if they
had just I mean yeah maybe not
completely ignore it but when it first
had happened when it first happened if
they had said well that I disagree with
that it's silly it's stupid it's
disrespectful make your point and then
move on and if the guy decides he wants
to sit for the rest of season whatever
its if he wants to do that but it's it's
just one guy right and for so long with
with the national anthem protest it was
only at it was Colin Kaepernick it was a
few other guys it was just a few guys
doing it it only became this huge
enormous thing and even then it was only
that for a few weeks where you had a lot
of players doing it but that only
happened after Donald Trump decided to
purposely resurrect the issue which had
basically died and then heading into the
2017 season he decided to bring it back
up again
and that's when it turned into this big
thing and even then it only lasted it
only like it only it only was like that
for a couple of weeks
if we had not done that
and we had just treated the protest as
the silly childish thing that it was
then it would it would have died away in
a few weeks and here would be three
years later
nobody would be talking about Colin
Kaepernick no one would even remember
him and and everyone will be better off
I think as for the boycott of of Nike
which is going on right now yeah to me
the the I'm not a big fan of our boycott
culture and this Nike boycott seems to
kind of perfectly encapsulate the
shallow virtue signaling character of
our boycott culture and that isn't now
don't get me wrong there are plenty of
really legitimate good reasons to
boycott Nike let's start with the fact
let's summer that well some earthy with
the here's the reason why I have always
boycotted them or have mostly boycotted
them I don't have like if I wanted to
burn my my Nike merchandise which I
wouldn't do anyway because that's
completely stupid and wasteful and if
you don't want to have your Nike
merchandise any more than what you could
do is give it to a person who's poor and
needs some clothing rather than burning
your $100 shoes maybe give them to
someone I mean you could go to pretty
much any City and find the homeless
person on the street who doesn't have
shoes maybe give him the shoes
just a thought anyway I don't really
have any Nike merchandise to burnt and
the reason for that I'll made it's it's
because that stuff it's ridiculously
expensive like I'm not gonna pay a
premium to have a little check mark on
my shoes I'm just not gonna pay that
right I could go I mean there's really
unless you're an athlete there's no
reason to spend more than 30 or 40 bucks
on a pair of sneakers if you're going
and spend 120 dollars on sneakers
because they have a check mark on them I
think that's pretty ridiculous so I was
boycotting them for that reason it's
more of a kind of practical utilitarian
reason another good reason to boycott
them is that they've used sweatshops
they have manufactured this ridiculously
overpriced merchandise on the backs of
child slaves it's a pretty good reason
not to purchase from them and
problem has not completely gone away
there be there's a report recently last
year that the company's workers in some
countries still are dealing with the
denial of wages sweltering heat well
over 90 degrees and the factories unsafe
conditions physical abuse and other
problems as well so that that's a very
sound basis for a boycott any time a
company is doing something that actually
hurts people they deserve to be
boycotted right yet
knowing about Nikes history with
sweatshops and I look I'm sorry I don't
buy I know they're I made this point a
few days ago and some people said well I
didn't know that Nike had a history of
sweatshops come on so has been common
knowledge for decades you really didn't
know that I find that hard to believe I
think most of us understood that it had
that history we also understand that
Nike sells its merchandise you know has
an unjustifiably high price for us
merchandise yet knowing all that the
current boycotters if they really are
boycotters that is people who have been
consistent customers of Nike and now no
longer will be that's what a boycott is
if you're boycotting Nike but you're
like me and you never really bought Nike
anyway well that's not a boycott you're
just continuing along what you were
already doing right but if they really
are boycotters and that means that the
boycotters gave their support to Nike in
spite of the sweatshop problem in spite
of the of the fact that the stuff is
ridiculously high-priced still gave
their support to Nike and now have only
exploded in fury and sworn off the
company because they saw a marketing
poster they didn't like I you know that
would seem to raise a question about
whether the boycott is really a campaign
for seeking justice or if it's just
another you know virtue signaling kind
of mob to join just another thing to do
another outrage to be a part of which
which I think well are with so many
boycotts that's really what it's all
about I don't think it's necessary or
wise to boycott every company that fails
to perfectly represent our political and
ideological views I don't think we need
to do that I think we should boycott
companies who do harmful things and evil
things companies like that should be
boycotted you can make a solid argument
that Nike falls into that category but
you could have made that argument for
the last like 30 years and if you never
made that argument before and now you're
suddenly making it I think it's a fair
question to ask why what changed all
that said I'll tell you what doesn't
me about the Nike campaign and in
general the reception that Kaepernick
has gotten on the left all right so I've
already told you what annoys me about
how the right has approached Kaepernick
so let me look over to the left now what
annoys me the most is
the cheapening of heroism this attempt
to make Kaepernick into some kind of
heroic figure some kind of martyr yeah I
mean it's it's ridiculous because he
isn't that we're told down Nikes telling
us he's sacrificed everything right
sacrificed everything which is quite a
statement and if you're telling me he
sacrificed everything then I we know he
didn't sacrifice everything so it's at
least hyperbole but if you're telling me
that that I shouldn't be able to look at
least one thing that he did sacrifice he
didn't sacrifice everything did he at
least sacrifice something I don't think
he did I mean let's let's look at this
for a moment he was a quarterback who
was you know had been on the on the
decline in his career although was most
read you know the last season he played
in the league there was a there's a
little bit of an uptick in his
production but generally speaking you
know Kaepernick there was about half of
one season where Kaepernick was getting
all this hype as he was the Nick who's
the next big thing in the NFL this this
transformational quarterback and all of
that died off very quickly and he hit
his peak and plummeted but that was his
trajectory and kind of that his peak
went to the Super Bowl he lost and he
plummeted from there now he was at best
a second string quarterback Talent
once he left San Francisco after
choosing to opt out of his contract by
the way so he chose to opt out of his
contract after the whole protest thing
then he opted out of his contract he
decided to be a free agent and then he
didn't end up on any other teams now if
this protest had not happened he
probably would have ended up on some
team probably on the bench somewhere or
potentially vying for a starting job in
like Buffalo or Cleveland or something
like that and he would have made it
would have maybe gotten three or four
years out of his career that way in
mediocrity
you know either maybe three four or five
years of riding the bench or of kind of
being on the quarterback carousel and
one of these markets like Buffalo or
Cleveland and then he would have retired
and and he would have been basically
basically forgotten instead so that that
that was the trajectory that he
sacrificed instead though he does this
protest
and now it's true that almost certainly
part of the reason why he couldn't find
another job in the NFL was because of
the protests he's not he was not a top
ten quarterback Talent but he was at
least a top 30 or 35 Talent which means
that all things being equal he would
have found a job somewhere on a roster
someone but all things were not equal
because teams are just not willing to
take on the distraction the attention
the hysteria for the sake of a second
string quarterback I mean if you're
going to as as an athlete if you're
gonna bring all of that hysteria to a
team
you better have enough talent the
competency a lot of talent Europe you
have to be an absolute star to
compensate for that and he's just not
that he doesn't haven't he didn't have
enough talent to compensate for the
distraction that he would bring so um
teams passed on him logically which is
it's not the first example of that
happening the same thing happened to Tim
Tebow Tim Tebow who never I mean
although there were people who were
offended by Tim Tebow for some
ridiculous reason there there was never
any reason to be offended by the guy
yeah Tim Tebow liked to kneel also but
he didn't kneel during the anthem you
know kneel on the sidelines or at
celebrating a touchdown or something
like that Tim Tebow's big big sin was
that he was a devout Christian and he
was known for his Christian faith but
the bigger problem for teams with Tim
Tebow is just that he you know he became
this this star who kind of transcended
the sport itself and people loved him
for reasons that it very little to do
with with football so he just had a ton
of attention on him yet he didn't have
the talent to necessarily be a starting
quarterback in the NFL consistently so
team said to themselves well we're not
yeah we're gonna bring this guy in put
him on the bench and then we got of all
this attention on this one guy who's
sitting on the bench and it's just a
distraction so team said you know we
don't we don't want that and so that's
why Tebow had trouble finding other jobs
in the NFL there are plenty of examples
of Dez Bryant is a you know was one of
the one of the best wives
Seavers in the game is on the decline
right now from you know after after
leaving the Cowboys he still hasn't
found a job on another on another team
because of all the attackers now he's
very different from team Tim Tebow but
he's a divisive kind of diva like
character and and there's a lot of just
distraction and it's just a distraction
and teams are not willing they don't
want to have that distraction on their
roster especially for a guy who can't
compensate for the distraction by being
an all-star talent so that's
[Music]
that's what happened to Kaepernick and
in fact there were reports that there
were a couple of there at least one team
that was looking at Kaepernick as being
possibly a second string quarterback he
turned down that offer he also turned
down offers to play for the the CFL the
Canadian Football League so this is not
someone who's desperate to go and play
football somewhere
comparing again to Tim Tebow but he
tried desperately to get on FL NFL
roster and stay on one he couldn't and
so then he goes he plays baseball I mean
this is a guy who just wants to play a
sport he's supposed to play ball this
really what he wants to do and so he'll
take any opportunity he can get
Kaepernick has not done that it seems
like Kaepernick is not it's just not a
ballplayer he's not interested in
playing ball he's more interested in in
being a kind of you know being this
Savior figure that he has turned himself
into so he chose to sacrifice three or
four years of bench warming or possibly
starting for some mid-market team and in
exchange he has international fame
accolades from the media a lucrative
sponsorship deal and other things and
that's a heck of a nice trade I would
say I mean I would take that trade
wouldn't you and that's why this isn't
martyrdom okay this isn't heroism
Kaepernick is neither a hero nor some
sort of great historic villain he's just
a guy who expressed his opinion and he
was punished for it but he was also
massively rewarded for it and the reward
I think way outweighs the punishment and
so that's all but that's not that's not
sacrifice and that's not heroism that's
a lot of different things that's it I
think among other things it's also a
calculation on his part where he had to
choose do I really want to try to stay
in the league and and play football or
do I want to go in and you know make it
and do this and have this be my brand
and build on that brand as the socially
conscious you know warrior for racial
equality kind of thing and he chose that
that path
and it's paid off for pretty well it
seems like our culture you know in our
culture we are just desperate for heroes
we're desperate for people to look up to
and so we select guys like Colin
Kaepernick
and on the other end as part of this
overall seeking of identity we're all so
desperate for easy villains that we can
hate and so we also select guys like
Colin Kapernick so I think that's where
this comes from that that's why even
though Colin Kaepernick is just some
quarterback who was on his way into
relative NFL obscurity yet he kneels for
the anthem a couple times and he becomes
this massive figure that we're talking
about for three years and why is that
it's just because it became this really
he became this really easy unchallenging
kind of mascot for both sides so on one
side they were able to take him and turn
him into some kind of hero on the other
side they could turn him into a villain
and it's easy it's unchallenging and on
both ends it's just ridiculous because
he's neither of those things he's a guy
with an opinion but made a decision and
a calculation paid off well for him
that's all all right and yet here I am
talking about him as well so I'm part of
the problem never claimed not to be so
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed